say mama i know i'm a cute boy
nicki minaj continues to put family
first
yes
and the barbs are living for this rare
photo of the family of three nikki
posted this pic on instagram wednesday
posing with her one-year-old son whom
she affectionately calls papa bear while
he sits on his dad and nicki's hubby
kenneth petty's shoulders
while the mama bear has kept her little
one pretty private we love getting a
glimpse of nikki's sweet family moments
like this adorable father-son shot of
papa bear in a yellow tracksuit paired
with none other than fendi high tops
it's spendy it's a big freaking deal but
it's the timing of the photo that has
some fans talking
as it comes just hours after kenneth was
reportedly sentenced to probation and
home detention for failing to register
as a sex offender stemming from a 1995
incident where kenneth was convicted of
attempted rape of a 16 year old girl
despite any legal chatter about her man
nikki is seemingly putting on a united
front as mrs petty meanwhile the rapper
seems to be focused on living her best
life as an artist mom and wife i mean
it's pretty obvious right
nikki and kenneth got married in october
2019 which she revealed by showing off
some mrs merch with her wedding date in
the caption
and the understated announcement seemed
to echo what nicki told et
days before secretly tying the knot when
i was little i always imagined you know
princess and marriage and wedding the
wedding and now
it's more to me about
the
the life the future the love the
partnership than the wedding which is so
strange because i didn't expect myself
to be one of those people who didn't
care about the hoopla since then the 39
year old grammy nominee has made some
big life changes pills and potions
nope no substance is for nicki in april
she tweeted that she's been sober and
loving life and added quote i used to be
happy when i was high now i'm happy when
i'm sober and no doubt nikki has a lot
to celebrate these days the rapper
returned to the met gala after skipping
the event two years in a row rocking an
all-black look by burberry
i love the hat um
i'm obsessed with the hat i didn't want
to do the look if i couldn't do the hat
and we have a feeling motherhood is
playing a big part in nicki's glow let's
be real who can resist priceless moments
like this
[Music]
you